hey it's kevin from big brother all
stars
and this is my e.t post eviction
interview
by a unanimous vote of six to zero
kevin you are evicted game everybody
let's hug up finale night let's have
happy hugs happy hugs
i was a block a lot this season because
i'm a block queen
oh like i don't know i think i was on
the block because
they saw a person who would just
take it and not really be able to
retaliate as much as i wanted to
retaliate i just could not
because the level of competition in this
house was so elevated and i was trying
to win comps
so that i could get back at them but i
just couldn't and they recognized that
really soon
and still they kept putting me on the
block
i'm mad i'm angry
i think the fire that i had the first
time i played the game
is different this time because
immediately i was put on the block and
immediately i was right i realized i was
on the outs
i could never ever penetrate
the major alliance i realized that
this cast is not feeling me like no one
is really welcoming me
whereas the first time i played the game
i thought
i see a way in this way i was like door
slamming
door slamming door slamming how would
you feel
if the door was slamming in your face
every single
day beat down and defeated and that's
how i felt this entire time
i'm exhausted right now because i've
been fighting for
weeks to find an angle and i could never
it's all fake julie you know that's all
fake stuff oh my god
i just didn't want to have those fake
hugs
you know
oh my god i told julie there's a lot of
fakery in this game because there
is a lot of fake folks in this house i
feel like i have some
cheap shake and go wigs that are less
fake than these house guests
and here's who i think is the
f cody
fake yeah i think those are the fakers a
lot of them everybody was really fake
including my i had to be fake sometimes
because i was like oh my god am i
supposed to be fake
is that like the thing that this season
like i couldn't get it so a lot of them
were asking
acting really fake
[Music]
because i'm black in japanese like it
happened in this house like even devon
said it
and so when i walk into this house and i
see two other people
that look like me
i'm in the mindset one two or three need
to be sitting in those final two chairs
and she kept saying it like only three
black people are in this house and i'm
like but i'm
half black i definite i am so looking
forward to having some
in-depth conversations in the jury house
with davon
because i feel like my uh we've never
really fully hashed out
the issues that i had as far as my own
identity and how i identify as a
biracial black and japanese person
and how she never really included me as
part of the
the uh part of the black house guest
and so i'm i can't wait to have some
serious conversations with her because i
think her perspective
is extremely valid as well and i just
want to talk about her perspective and
my
perspective and how we can find some
commonality there